So one of the things that's happening right now around the world is that you have all these couples-- happy ones, struggling couples, couples in that kind of things seem OK, but I don't know haze. Tens of millions of couples confined for weeks now, the relationships being remolded by this lockdown.
目前世界各地正在发生的一件事是，你拥有了所有这些伴侣——快乐的、挣扎的、看似还好但又不知道是不是在迷雾中的伴侣。数千万对伴侣被禁足数周，他们的关系正因这次封锁而重塑。
It's an accelerator. It's a relationship accelerator. So it rearranges the priority and throws the superfluous overboard in a very clarifying way for many of us.
这是一种催化剂，一种关系催化剂。所以它重新安排了优先级，并以一种对我们许多人来说非常清晰的方式，将多余的东西抛弃。
Wondering what's happening with couples, I reached out to Esther Perel, who's a couples therapist. If you've heard of her, she's probably best known for this idea from her book, Mating in Captivity, that it takes a toll on couples and kills passion when there's not enough distance between the partners. And they turn to each other for everything. For friendship, and a sense of identity, and comfort, and everything a whole village used to provide a person. And she's very aware that under lockdown, people are literally turning to their partners for everything.
出于对伴侣关系现状的好奇，我联系了伴侣治疗师埃丝特·佩瑞尔。如果你听说过她，她最出名的应该是她书《圈养中的交配》里的观点，即当伴侣之间缺乏足够的距离时，会对彼此造成伤害并扼杀激情。他们向对方索求一切，包括友谊、身份认同、安慰，以及曾经由整个社区为个人提供的一切。她非常清楚，在封锁状态下，人们确实在向伴侣索求一切。
These days, she's seeing a full schedule of couples, more than she usually does. Interestingly, she says this is an unusually good moment for therapy. And in lockdown, lots of clients who are opening up and figuring out things in ways they don't normally, like some of the men in the couples--
这些天，她的预约排得满满当当，比平时还要多。有趣的是，她说这是进行治疗的异常好的时机。在封锁期间，许多客户开始敞开心扉，以他们通常不会的方式理清头绪，比如伴侣中的一些男性——
It's like for the first time, they're actually doing therapy. It's exciting, basically because they stopped. They slowed down their home. And they're like this blossoming of opening up and--
就像他们第一次真正地在接受治疗。这很令人兴奋，基本上是因为他们停下来了。他们放慢了家庭生活的节奏。他们就像处于一种绽放的开放状态，并且——
Wow.
哇。
Three dudes, you know, three men-- it's just exci-- like I don't want to get off the phone because it's very moving.
三个家伙，你知道，三个男人——这真是太令人兴奋了，我都不想挂断电话，因为这非常感人。
For most of the couples that you're seeing, what's your sense? Has the lockdown been good for them or bad for them?
在你见过的多数伴侣中，你的感觉如何？封锁对他们来说是好事还是坏事？
Hm. It's just such an interesting thing to see. Really both, really both. I can't say one or the other.
嗯。这确实是非常有趣的事情。两者都有，真的两者都有。我不能说是其中任何一种。
The couples struggling the most are pretty much exactly the ones you'd expect, people who even before all this were quick to pick at their partners, and criticize them, and argue over who's sacrificing the most for whom. But also in this moment when our lives have been so profoundly disrupted, another group doing badly--
那些挣扎得最厉害的伴侣，基本和你预料的一样，即使在这之前也总是喜欢指责对方、批评对方，并争论谁为谁牺牲得更多。但在我们生活受到如此剧烈冲击的时刻，另一群处境糟糕的人是——
People who-- they've lost someone, or they have someone who's sick, or they are anxious. They are worried. And basically their partner is unable to have an emphatic response. You know, what are you worried about? There's nothing. And people tell you, my partner is the last person I'm turning to for anything I'm feeling right now. It's like I have nowhere to go with this, to just be able to be upset, or scared, or this constant sense of loss just of the world they've known, their own identity, their work, all of that.
那些失去亲人的人，或者有家人生病的人，或者是感到焦虑的人。他们很担心。而他们的伴侣却无法给予同理心的回应。你知道，他们会说“你担心什么？什么事都没有”。人们告诉我，在现在这种状态下，我的伴侣是我最不想求助的人。感觉就像我无处排解，无法表达自己的难过、恐惧，或者那种对已知世界的丧失感，对自己身份、工作等的持续失落感。
The extreme circumstances are also driving people to re-prioritize. Esther has seen couples split up and others move in together. And one of her most fascinating role reversals-- she's counseling one couple where one of the partners was always seen as the insecure one. She'd struggled through a traumatic childhood. It was agreed between the two of them that she was the troubled one who leaned on her stronger, more together partner. But now with the deadly virus everywhere, she's found that her difficult childhood gave her all kinds of coping and managing skills.
极端环境也促使人们重新划分优先级。埃丝特见过伴侣分手，也见过他们搬到一起住。她最迷人的角色反转之一是她正在辅导的一对伴侣，其中一方总是被视为缺乏安全感的人。她经历过一段创伤性的童年。两人一致认为她是那个脆弱、依赖更强大且更成熟伴侣的人。但现在，面对遍布各地的致命病毒，她发现自己艰难的童年赋予了她各种应对和处理危机的技能。
She's basically, I have known chaos. You put me in this crisis. I know what to do. I knew what to do before anybody around me.
她基本上是说，我了解混乱。你把我放进这种危机里。我知道该怎么做。我比周围任何人都先知道该怎么做。
I was in that supermarket. I even knew to get the stuff for the parents of my girlfriend who is not even here because I knew that they would need this. And I just felt like now the world is clear to me. I know what it needs from me.
我在那家超市里。我甚至知道为我女朋友的父母买东西，她甚至都不在那里，因为我知道他们会需要这些。我只是觉得现在世界对我来说很清晰。我知道它需要我做什么。
And in this particular relationship, it's two women. And it was a very interesting thing because it had-- I don't think that side of her had ever been known. It had always been described as you're the one with the issues because you come from this very traumatic background.
在这段特别的关系中，这是两位女性。这是一件非常有趣的事情，因为以前——我不认为她那一面曾经被了解过。她总是被描述为“你有问题的那个人”，因为你来自那个非常有创伤的背景。
So she became the functional one in the relationship.
所以她成了这段关系中能够解决问题的那个人。
It was like a whole different way of being, but it was also a revelation to her self. This turned everything around.
这不仅是一种完全不同的存在方式，对她自己来说也是一种启示。这彻底扭转了一切。
Suddenly, she wasn't seeking her partner's approval all the time. She didn't need it, which, of course, is healthy and great, except for the partner who is used to being the strong one. It's one thing to wish that the person you're with is more assertive and less needy. What do you do when you get that wish? It made her uncomfortable. And the way this played out did not surprise Esther.
突然间，她不再一直寻求伴侣的认可。她不再需要它了，这当然是健康且棒的，除了对那个习惯于扮演强者角色的伴侣来说。希望和你在一起的人更自信、更少需求是一回事。但当你真的实现了这个愿望时，你该怎么办？这让她感到不舒服。而这种表现出来的方式并没有让埃丝特感到意外。
Oh, when I'm not comfortable with someone who is emancipating right next to me, I basically try to make them doubt themselves again. Because if they doubt themselves, if they're not sure, then they come to me.
哦，当我面对一个正在我身边寻求独立的人感到不舒服时，我基本上会尝试让他们再次怀疑自己。因为如果他们怀疑自己，如果他们不确定，他们就会回到我身边。
So that's what she was doing?
所以这就是她在做的？
Yes, in all kinds of very subtle ways, of course. This is not flagrant.
是的，当然是以各种非常微妙的方式。这不是公然的。
So she would say things to encourage her formerly dependent partner to second-guess herself, to doubt herself, things like--
所以她会说一些话来鼓励她曾经依赖的伴侣重新审视自己，怀疑自己，比如——
It's so interesting that you want to do that. I thought you didn't really-- that that was not what you wanted to do. Or you once mentioned to me that you don't want to bring your mom, you don't want to call your father.
你想要做那个，真是太有趣了。我以为你并不真的——那不是你想做的。或者你曾经跟我提过，你不想带你妈妈，你不想给你爸爸打电话。
Little doubts.
小小的疑虑。
It's a bit of a mind twist, just gentle mind twists. You don't mean to. It looks like it's a very rational conversation.
这是一种心灵扭曲，只是温柔的心灵扭曲。你不是故意的。这看起来就像是一次非常理性的对话。
With other couples, Esther Perel says being on lockdown is forcing them to confront things that they'd been avoiding, but have never actually stopped to figure out. There's a couple like this on her podcast. She does a show called Where Should We Begin?, where she records therapy sessions with real couples who volunteer to do this anonymously on a podcast.
对于其他伴侣，埃丝特·佩瑞尔说，封锁迫使他们面对那些一直在回避、但从未真正停下来搞清楚的事情。她的播客里就有一对这样的伴侣。她主持一个名为《我们从哪里开始？》的节目，记录与志愿在播客上匿名进行治疗的真实伴侣的谈话。
Right now all the sessions are couples on lockdown. In episode two of the season, the couple was living apart before COVID-19. They had been together, living in Italy, but she got a job offer in Germany, caused a huge rift. She moved to Germany with her teenage daughter. He didn't. Then this year, when it really became a hotspot for the virus, he finally moved in with them. And finally, he and she had to deal with each other.
现在所有的课程都是关于封锁中的伴侣。在本季的第二集中，这对伴侣在新冠肺炎疫情之前是分居的。他们曾住在一起，住在意大利，但她得到了德国的一份工作机会，造成了巨大的裂痕。她带着十几岁的女儿搬到了德国。他没有。然后今年，当那里真正成为病毒重灾区时，他终于搬去和她们住了。最终，他和她不得不面对彼此。
They were on the verge of divorcing the moment this is over. This is an interesting situation because COVID-19 basically brought them together under one roof. They have been apart for a year and a half, and each one feels the other one abandoned them.
一旦疫情结束，他们就处于离婚的边缘。这是一个有趣的情况，因为新冠病毒基本上把他们带到了同一个屋檐下。他们已经分开了一年半，每个人都觉得对方抛弃了自己。
So COVID-19 resolved the standoff between them because neither of them had to make the decision, because the virus decided. And now they're under the same roof. And neither of them had to give in. But once they're together, they are in a constant-- it's like one person talks, the other one listens until they find a thing they can disagree with. And that's where they enter. And now they're going to start arguing.
所以新冠病毒解决了他们之间的僵局，因为他们谁都不需要做决定，病毒替他们做了决定。现在他们住在一起了。谁也不必让步。但一旦在一起，他们就陷入了不断的——就像一个人说话，另一个人听着，直到他们找到可以反驳的地方。那就是他们切入点。然后他们就开始争论了。
And it's interesting. There's a point where they keep having the same fight over and over. And you keep saying to them, stop having this fight. And there's a moment in the session where he actually is being kind to her and sort of inviting. And it's so interesting what happens.
这很有趣。有那么一个点，他们一直在重复同样的争吵。你一直告诉他们，别再吵了。在会话中有那么一刻，他实际上是在对她好，表现得很邀请。发生的事情非常有趣。
Like you said, I am very busy. And today, I wanted to cook for you instead of doing something else. So I did that without even telling you. And these are the things that you don't appreciate.
就像你说的，我很忙。今天，我本来想为你做饭，而不是做别的事。所以我没告诉你直接做了。这些都是你不领情的地方。
No, I appreciate, but would have been better if I would have cooked and then we were eating all together. So you did a great thing today to cook the lunch. But you didn't have lunch with us basically because you were between two calls. You had just five minutes to eat.
不，我领情，但如果我做饭，然后我们一起吃会更好。所以你今天做午餐很棒。但你基本上没和我们一起吃，因为你在两个电话之间。你只有五分钟时间吃饭。
And I prefer to eat anything with you besides you cooking to let us eat, you know what I mean? I don't know. Let's plan what makes us happy maybe 'cause would have been better if we would have shared those 15 minutes of the lunch.
我宁愿和你一起随便吃点，也不愿你为了让我们吃而专门做饭，你知道我的意思吗？我不知道。也许我们计划一下什么能让我们快乐，因为如果我们能分享那15分钟的午餐会更好。
I also can't make it right.
我也没法让你满意。
No, no. But there is nothing wrong.
不，不。但没有任何问题。
Did you hear this as a criticism?
你把这当成批评了吗？
Yes.
是的。
But it's not. It's not. I'm just saying I would love to have lunch with you, and I would prefer to cook instead of you. If you have to spend those 15 minutes cooking for us, it's better that you make one call in those 15 minutes while I'm cooking and then you dedicate the next 15 minutes just to eat together. I'm not criticizing anything.
但不是。真的不是。我只是说我希望能和你一起吃午餐，我宁愿做饭而不是让你做。如果你必须花那15分钟给我们做饭，不如在我做饭的时候你打个电话，然后接下来的15分钟专门用来一起吃饭。我没有批评任何事。
But I'm scared to ask you to cook again because I see all the things that you're doing right.
但我不敢再请你做饭了，因为我看到你把所有事情都做对了。
What the fuck? I'm just cooking.
什么鬼？我只是在做饭。
One second, one second, one second. This moment was important. If you go to a class, you'd miss this, because you want to know if he cares. And he just told you. I would rather eat with you, whatever. He just gave it to you on a platter.
等一下，等一下，等一下。这一刻很重要。如果你去上课，你会错过这个，因为你想知道他是否在乎。而他刚刚告诉了你。我宁愿和你一起吃，无论吃什么。他刚把它端到你面前。
But you only heard the piece about it would have been better if you hadn't cooked. You didn't hear that what he meant with that was because I would have wanted that time with you. It's like you hear that which you want to hear, even if it's what you fear hearing and that you're not hearing what he's actually telling you. I'm not so sure that love is gone, but I think that the lovers have become invisible to the love that is.
但你只听到了“如果没做饭会更好”那一部分。你没听到他这样说的本意是因为我想和你共度那段时光。就像你只听你想听的，即使那是你害怕听到的，而你没有听到他实际上在告诉你什么。我不确定爱是否已经消失，但我认为爱人对于现有的爱变得不可见了。
That's-- wow. But she just said, oh my god, that was the wow effect.
那是——哇。但她刚才说，天哪，那是“哇”的效果。
She says this thing to the couple that-- I don't know-- maybe anybody who's ever been in a couple would find useful. She says to them, notice that behind every criticism there's a wish, a wish to be closer. Esther says she sees other couples in the same situation as this one. They're stuck in the same fight, and everything leads back to that fight, everything the other person says.
她对这对伴侣说了一些——不知道——也许任何有过伴侣关系的人都会觉得有用的话。她对他们说，注意，在每一次批评背后都有一个愿望，一个想要更亲近的愿望。埃丝特说她看到其他伴侣也处于这种情况。他们被困在同样的争吵中，一切都归结于那场争吵，对方说的每一句话都归结于此。
And they're too far gone to fix it. But what this couple was able to do, she says, was put aside the fight for a moment and talk about the feelings they were having for each other underneath all that. By the end of the therapy session, they're speaking in a sincere and heartfelt way that they hadn't in a long time.
他们走得太远，无法挽回了。但她说，这对伴侣能够做到的，是把争吵暂时放在一边，谈谈在那之下他们对彼此的真实感受。在治疗结束时，他们以一种真诚、发自内心的、很久没有过的方式在交谈。
So I called you when this crisis started, and you came to take care of us. And I appreciate that. And I don't want to lose this.
所以我在这场危机开始时给你打了电话，你来照顾我们。我很感激。我不想失去这个。
This COVID-19 for this couple will save the couple that was literally otherwise on its way out. They were going to do another one year of fighting like this. And then one of them would meet somebody else, and that would be the end of that story. 17 years-- it's not like they've just met yesterday.
对于这对伴侣来说，新冠疫情将拯救这段原本即将结束的关系。他们本打算再吵一年。然后其中一个会遇到别人，故事就结束了。17年——他们不是昨天才认识的。
Other couples don't get to this point. Episode three of her podcast this season has another couple who cannot stop themselves from fighting the same fight over and over. They decided to divorce two weeks before lockdown. And since then, it's gotten so much worse.
其他伴侣没能走到这一步。她播客本季的第三集有另一对伴侣，他们无法停止一遍又一遍地争吵。他们在封锁前两周决定离婚。从那时起，情况变得更糟了。
What's hurting me, living with someone who has so much contempt for me and feels that I am trying to control you by asking you to isolate with your family, which is what the governor is asking us to do. And I'm sorry that that doesn't work with your social plans, but this is a time that people are suffering.
让我痛苦的是，和这样一个蔑视我的人生活在一起，他觉得我要求你和家人隔离是在控制你，而这正是政府要求我们做的。我很抱歉这和你的社交计划不符，但现在是人们正在受苦的时候。
I'm not arguing that. I can't argue with you anymore.
我没在争论那个。我没法再和你争论了。
No, but you are.
不，你就是在争。
I'm saying I'm not happy about it.
我说我对此不高兴。
But you are. You were arguing--
但你就是。你昨天还在争论——
I don't just feel like I have a choice.
我只是觉得我没得选。
You were arguing as of yesterday.
你昨天还在争论。
It's interesting. You lecture them in that episode a few times with a tone I feel like we don't usually hear from you.
很有趣。你在那一集中多次用一种我觉得通常听不到的语气教训他们。
Yes. I'm basically saying, you have a task to accomplish. You are in lockdown together. And this is your mission right now. That's your project.
是的。我基本上是在说，你们有一个任务要完成。你们被封锁在一起。这就是你们现在的使命。那是你们的项目。
What you feel about each other is rather irrelevant. You are two parents. You chose to be here in this house together. What are you going to do, piss on each other the whole time just to remind the other that you resent having to be here? Or are you just simply going to try to be as civil as you can be and make this tolerable for everyone?
你们对彼此的感觉并不重要。你们是两个父母。你们选择在这里一起生活。你们打算怎么办，一直互相折磨，只是为了提醒对方你怨恨不得不待在这里吗？还是你们打算仅仅努力表现得礼貌一些，让每个人都过得去？
For so many couples, the stress of lockdown makes things worse. There are already reports from China, as it comes out of lockdown, that divorce may be on the rise there. So who are the couples who are doing better?
对许多伴侣来说，封锁的压力让情况变得更糟。已经有来自中国的报道称，随着封锁解除，离婚率可能会上升。那么，哪些伴侣做得更好呢？
Who does better is the people who think, what can I learn here? What is this telling me about what actually matters in my life or what I really want to do and becoming more aware of things? Because A, we have never slowed down like this. Never on a global level have we slowed down like this. It's a long time that we have only been accelerating, accelerating, accelerating. And for the first time-- and I don't think we have begun even to understand what this is going to do to you to have had to really experience what that kind of a slowdown will do.
做得更好的是那些思考“我在这里能学到什么？”的人。这对我生活中真正重要的事情，或者我真正想做的事情有什么启示？开始对事情有更多觉知。因为第一，我们从来没有这样放慢过脚步。在全球层面上，我们从来没有这样放慢过。很长一段时间以来，我们一直只有加速、加速、加速。而第一次——我不认为我们已经开始理解，不得不真正体验那种减速会给你带来什么。
Who we'll all be when this is done, who knows, seriously? Trying to guess the ultimate effect of this national shutdown on couples, on our kids' education, on the economy, on ourselves, it's like the virus has thrown the future into this black box. We can make our guesses, or we can just accept we'll know when we know. And for those of us who like more certainty in our lives, well, tough luck.
这一切结束后我们会成为什么样的人，谁知道呢，说真的？试图猜测这次全国范围的停摆对伴侣、对我们孩子教育、对经济、对我们自己的最终影响，就像病毒把未来扔进了这个黑箱。我们可以做出猜测，或者我们可以接受事实，到时候自然就知道了。而对于那些喜欢生活中更多确定性的人来说，好吧，真不走运。
Today on our program, we have people trying in various situations to live with a lack of information, not happy about that fact at all, but doing their best. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有处于各种情况下的人，试图在缺乏信息的情况下生活，对这个事实一点也不高兴，但都在尽力而为。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, A Phone Flickers in the Dark. There's one part of the world where there's a kind of information vacuum. At least for those of us who aren't there, it's a kind of black box. It's Xinjiang, China.
第一幕，黑暗中闪烁的手机。世界上有一个地方存在信息真空。至少对于我们这些不在那里的人来说，它是一个黑箱。那就是中国新疆。
If you picture China, it's in the northwest corner, far from China's big cities, the size of Mexico, nestled up against Kazakhstan, and a few other Stans. And ethnically it's been more like them than 90% of China. For instance, it's home to the Uyghurs, who speak their own language that's close to Turkish, not Mandarin Chinese. Most Uyghurs are Muslim. And for a long time, the Uyghurs faced discrimination and arbitrary detention in China.
如果你想象中国，它位于西北角，远离中国大城市，有墨西哥那么大，毗邻哈萨克斯坦和其他几个斯坦国。在民族文化上，它比中国90%的地方更像它们。例如，它是维吾尔族的家园，他们说自己的语言，接近土耳其语，而不是汉语。大多数维吾尔人是穆斯林。长期以来，维吾尔人面临歧视和任意拘留。
If you follow the news, you probably know that this escalated beginning in 2014 when the government started accusing hundreds of thousands of Uyghurs of supporting terrorism and wanting to separate from China, and sent them to so-called re-education centers. They're better described as internment camps. Former detainees report being beaten. Women have testified that they were forcibly sterilized.
如果你关注新闻，你可能知道这在2014年升级，当时政府开始指控数十万维吾尔人支持恐怖主义并想要从中国分裂出去，并将他们送入所谓的“再教育中心”。它们被描述为拘留营更贴切。前被拘留者报告遭到殴打。妇女们作证说她们被强迫绝育。
The State Department has estimated that up to two million people were held in these camps. But information about what's really going on in Xinjiang is hard to come by. And for Uyghurs outside of Xinjiang who want to check in on their families back home, well, some families are effectively blocked from all communication. Others, the government monitors phone calls, and you don't want to say anything that will lead to officials banging on your family's door.
国务院估计有高达两百万人被关押在这些营地中。但关于新疆真实情况的信息很难获得。对于想要了解家乡亲人情况的境外维吾尔人来说，好吧，有些家庭的通讯被完全切断了。另一些，政府监控电话，你不想说任何会导致官员敲开你家人门的话。
So Uyghurs in the diaspora have turned to TikTok. Yes, older listeners, you think of TikTok as the app where the kids are making dance videos and jokes that you do not understand. But the app started in China. The Chinese version of TikTok is called Douyin. It is insanely popular, over 400 million users a day.
所以侨民中的维吾尔人转而使用TikTok。是的，年长的听众，你认为TikTok是孩子们制作舞蹈视频和你不理解的笑话的应用程序。但这应用起源于中国。TikTok的中国版叫抖音。它极其流行，每天超过4亿用户。
And because it's so visual, the government is not so great at censoring it. As a result, it's a place where uncensored content gets out of Xinjiang. There are videos posted by Uyghurs, but also by government officials who've been sent there to manage Uyghurs. Here is a TikTok video that seems to have been posted by an official who's been assigned to live with a Uyghur family in their house as a kind of minder. It seems like maybe he posted this to show everything's fine. We're getting along. Everything's great.
而且因为它非常直观，政府在审查它方面不太擅长。结果，它成为了一个未受审查的内容从新疆流出的地方。有维吾尔人发布的视频，也有被派去管理维吾尔人的政府官员发布的视频。这是一个TikTok视频，似乎是由一名被指派住进维吾尔家庭充当监督者的官员发布的。看起来他发布这个是为了展示一切正常。我们相处得很好。一切都很棒。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
In the video, the minder is eating breakfast with the two kids from the family in the garden. He smiles at the camera, turns it to the little boy eating next to him. And then in Uyghur, the boy says to his mom--
视频中，监督者正和家里的两个孩子在花园里吃早餐。他对着镜头微笑，转过来对着坐在他旁边吃东西的小男孩。然后用维吾尔语，男孩对妈妈说——
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
--"When my dad comes home, this guy will leave."
“等我爸爸回家，这家伙就会离开。”
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
"Mom, is he coming on Monday?" The official doesn't seem to understand a word of that. Now here is a video posted presumably by somebody who's Uyghur. It's a woman with long, dark hair sitting in her car while the song "Faded" by Alan Walker plays in the background.
“妈妈，他周一会来吗？”官员似乎一个字都没听懂。现在这是一个据推测由维吾尔人发布的视频。这是一个留着长深色头发的女人坐在车里，背景播放着艾伦·沃克的歌曲《Faded》。
[MUSIC - ALAN WALKER, "FADED"]
[音乐 - 艾伦·沃克，《Faded》]
There's something off about this. It is not a normal TikTok video of somebody dancing. She's beating her chest with her fist to the beat. And then you realize there are dozens of these same kind of video, using the same song, everybody beating their chest. It's like a virtual protest.
这有点不对劲。这不是一个正常的别人跳舞的TikTok视频。她随着节拍用拳头捶打自己的胸口。然后你意识到有几十个这样的视频，用同样的歌，每个人都在捶胸。就像一场虚拟的抗议。
Still, like I say, there are lots of Uyghurs trying to figure out what's going on in Xinjiang and what's happening to their own families there. Durrie Bouscaren is a reporter living in Turkey, where a lot of Uyghurs have settled, many of them in the last five years. She's been talking with one man for months who's been obsessed with these TikTok videos, with anything else he can find that'll give him a look inside Xinjiang's black box because what he values the most in this world, his wife, and son, and the rest of his family, are stuck inside. Here's Durrie.
尽管如此，就像我说的，有很多维吾尔人在试图弄清楚新疆发生了什么，以及他们自己的家人在那里发生了什么。杜里·布斯卡伦是一位住在土耳其的记者，那里定居着许多维吾尔人，其中许多是在过去五年里来的。她几个月来一直与一名男子交谈，他沉迷于这些TikTok视频，以及任何他能找到的能让他窥视新疆黑箱内部的东西，因为他在这世界上最珍视的东西——他的妻子、儿子和其他家人，都被困在里面。这是杜里。
Abdurahman Tohti fled China seven years ago after getting arrested and tortured for learning Arabic. He wanted to read the Quran. Today, he still doesn't have much feeling in his feet.
阿卜杜拉赫曼·托赫蒂七年前逃离中国，因为他因学习阿拉伯语而被逮捕和折磨。他想读《古兰经》。今天，他的脚仍然没什么感觉。
But let me tell you how he met his wife, because it's a sweet story. When Abdurahman got to Istanbul, he wanted to settle down and start a family of his own. So he turned to his dad back in Xinjiang, the person he trusts most in the world, and asked him to help him find someone back home for him to marry.
但让我告诉你他是如何遇见妻子的，因为这是一个甜蜜的故事。当阿卜杜拉赫曼到达伊斯坦布尔时，他想安顿下来，开始自己的家庭。所以他求助于在新疆的父亲，他在这世界上最信任的人，请他帮他在老家找个人结婚。
His dad went around, talked to other parents. And he found Peride, a biology student with brown eyes and a kind face. Abdurahman and Peride talked on WeChat. That's the main social media platform in China. They couldn't say much because they knew the government monitored calls to foreign numbers.
他的父亲四处打听，和别的家长交谈。他找到了佩里黛，一个有着棕色眼睛和慈祥面孔的生物学学生。阿卜杜拉赫曼和佩里黛在微信上聊天。那是中国主要的社交媒体平台。他们不能说太多，因为他们知道政府监控拨打国际号码的电话。
The conversation was stilted, but they got a sense for each other. And they decided to get married. So she packed her bags and boarded a plane to Turkey. Abdurahman was so excited.
对话很生硬，但他们对彼此有了感觉。他们决定结婚。所以她收拾行囊，登上了飞往土耳其的飞机。阿卜杜拉赫曼太激动了。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
So the plane arrived at 2 o'clock in the night. So I went to the airport to pick her up. I bought a big rose flower, and I put a Quran in the middle. And I put a ring on the top of the Quran for picking her up from airport.
飞机在凌晨2点到达。所以我去机场接她。我买了一朵大玫瑰花，在中间放了一本《古兰经》。并在《古兰经》上放了一枚戒指，等着在机场接她。
He brought a photo of her to make sure he could figure out who she was. He was in the terminal with a group of friends, waiting. People were streaming out of the customs area, and he sees her.
他带了一张她的照片，确保能认出她是谁。他在航站楼里和一群朋友等着。人们从海关区涌出，他看到了她。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
I go to her, and I ask, is this you on the picture? She asked, who is the girl in the picture for you? So I said, it's my wife. So she said, are you crazy? You don't recognize your wife? Then she left. It wasn't her.
我走到她面前，问，照片上的人是你吗？她问，照片上的女孩对你来说是谁？我说，是我妻子。她说，你疯了吗？你不认得你妻子？然后她走了。那不是她。
It's not Peride. And Abdurahman's starting to worry, like maybe she's not coming. Then he sees someone else who looks like her, goes up to her, shows the picture. She's like, no, that's not me. But as he's turning to leave, she calls him back. It was her.
那不是佩里黛。阿卜杜拉赫曼开始担心，也许她没来。然后他看到另一个人看起来像她，走过去，展示照片。她说，不，那不是我。但当他转身离开时，她把他叫住。那是她。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
She took her phone out and show me my picture and asks me, are you this guy in the phone, in the picture? And I say yes. And that's why we met first time.
她拿出手机给我看我的照片，问我，手机里照片上的这个人是你吗？我说，是。这就是我们第一次见面的原因。
She was messing with him.
她在逗他。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
I put a ring on her hand. And the girl has a flower. And the Turks around us asking, what's happening? Are you getting married? Where are you from?
我给她戴上戒指。女孩拿着花。周围的土耳其人问，发生什么事了？你们要结婚吗？你们从哪儿来的？
Suddenly, it became a kind of party. People are giving us gifts, all kinds of chocolate candies, and saying congratulations. And it was a really happy moment for us.
突然，这变成了一种聚会。人们给我们送礼物，各种巧克力糖果，说恭喜。这对我们来说是一个非常幸福的时刻。
A police officer working at the airport says, hey, I'm Uyghur too. He gives them a police escort back home, lights flashing. It's like a movie.
机场里的一名警察说，嘿，我也是维吾尔人。他给了他们警察护送回家的待遇，闪着警灯。就像电影一样。
Not too long after, Abdurahman and Peride had a son. They named him Abduleziz, after his grandfather. And Abduleziz becomes his dad's mini me. Everything Abdurahman did, Abduleziz would follow, from the way he stood to his table manners.
没过多久，阿卜杜拉赫曼和佩里黛就有了一个儿子。他们给他取名阿卜杜勒阿齐兹，以他祖父的名字命名。阿卜杜勒阿齐兹成了他父亲的“迷你版”。阿卜杜拉赫曼做的一切，阿卜杜勒阿齐兹都会跟着做，从他站立的方式到餐桌礼仪。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
He likes the car. Even when I'm driving my car, he wants to sit in front of me and drive with me.
他喜欢车。即使我开车时，他也想坐在我前面一起开。
This was in a parking lot. Abdurahman was teaching Peride how to drive, and 18-month-old Abduleziz would sit on his dad's lap and grab the stick shift. He'd throw a fuss if he couldn't.
这是在停车场。阿卜杜拉赫曼在教佩里黛开车，18个月大的阿卜杜勒阿齐兹会坐在他爸爸腿上抓住档位杆。如果不能这样做，他会发脾气。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
He was really cute. He used to try to copy everything I do.
他真的很可爱。他过去常试着模仿我所做的一切。
But Abdurahman's relationship with Peride's family was rocky right from the start. Abdurahman is religious, but her family is secular and pretty wealthy. But the heart of the problem was that Peride's parents felt like she was wasting her education in Turkey. She had a degree, but she wasn't using it. She wanted to stay home with their son.
但阿卜杜拉赫曼与佩里黛家人的关系从一开始就很紧张。阿卜杜拉赫曼很虔诚，但她的家人是世俗的，而且相当富有。但问题的核心是，佩里黛的父母觉得她在土耳其浪费了她的教育。她有学位，但没用上。她想待在家里陪儿子。
When Abduleziz was born, Peride's parents started asking her to come back to Xinjiang for a long visit, maybe even to leave Abduleziz with them for a while. In Uyghur families, it's really common for grandparents to take care of their grandkids for their first five years of life while the parents work. The pressure from back home got really intense, but Abdurahman and Peride were hesitant to leave Turkey.
阿卜杜勒阿齐兹出生时，佩里黛的父母开始要求她回新疆住上一长段时间，甚至把阿卜杜勒阿齐兹留在他们那里一段时间。在维吾尔家庭中，祖父母照顾孙辈出生后的前五年非常普遍，而父母则忙于工作。来自家乡的压力变得非常大，但阿卜杜拉赫曼和佩里黛对离开土耳其持犹豫态度。
For starters, Abdurahman couldn't go with her to Xinjiang because he was sure he'd be arrested if he returned to China. And by this point, it was 2015. They'd been hearing whispers about added surveillance, about Uyghurs being detained in Xinjiang. They don't know exactly what's happening, but they know it's not good.
首先，阿卜杜拉赫曼不能陪她去新疆，因为他肯定如果他回中国就会被捕。到这时，已经是2015年了。他们听到了关于加强监视、关于维吾尔人在新疆被拘留的传言。他们不知道到底发生了什么，但知道情况不妙。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
I asked my wife, what do you say? If you want to with them, we can try it, but I don't feel good about it. And I'm afraid you will not be able to come back again because of the situation down there. She said, no, are you crazy? I really don't want to travel.
我问妻子，你怎么看？如果你想和他们一起，我们可以试试，但我觉得不好。我怕你以后再也回不来了，因为那边的情况。她说，不，你疯了吗？我真的不想去旅游。
Peride's parents kept insisting that it was safe, at least for them. They were loyal to the party, and they had high level government contacts. They're not religious. If Abduleziz was with them, they said, it would be OK. They were pushing, but Abdurahman and Peride kept saying no.
佩里黛的父母坚持认为这是安全的，至少对他们来说是这样。他们忠于党，并且有高级政府联系。他们不信教。如果阿卜杜勒阿齐兹和他们在一起，他们说，那会没事的。他们一直在施压，但阿卜杜拉赫曼和佩里黛一直在拒绝。
A few months later, Abdurahman was walking by a pretzel shop in his neighborhood when the police stopped him and asked for his residency papers. His permit had lapsed. He'd applied for a new one, but it hadn't arrived yet. So they arrested him, took him to a detention center.
几个月后，阿卜杜拉赫曼走过他家附近的一家椒盐卷饼店时，警察拦住他，要求出示居留证。他的许可证过期了。他申请了新的，但还没到。所以他们逮捕了他，把他带到了拘留中心。
This happens to a fair number of Uyghurs in Turkey. They'll be detained for a paperwork issue, and they'll get stuck for a while. In Abdurahman's case, he was locked up for three months, allowed just one phone call home every week. Peride, meanwhile, was home alone with their toddler and pregnant, close to her due date.
在土耳其，有相当一部分维吾尔人遇到这种情况。他们会因为文书问题被拘留，并被困一段时间。阿卜杜拉赫曼被关了三个月，每周只允许打一个电话回家。佩里黛同时独自在家照顾蹒跚学步的孩子，而且怀孕了，快到预产期。
When Abdurahman finally got out, his whole world had changed. His wife had given birth to their second child, a girl. And his son, Abduleziz, was gone. He was in China. Peride's mother had come for a visit and arranged for the trip back.
当阿卜杜拉赫曼终于出来时，他的整个世界都变了。妻子生下了他们的第二个孩子，一个女孩。而他的儿子阿卜杜勒阿齐兹不见了。他在中国。佩里黛的母亲来访并安排了那次返程旅行。
Abdurahman felt tricked. He didn't even get to say goodbye. It's like his in-laws waited until he couldn't interfere and then sent his kid away. He says he never would have let Abduleziz go to China.
阿卜杜拉赫曼觉得被骗了。他甚至没能告别。就像他的岳父母等他无法干预时才把他的孩子送走。他说他绝不会让阿卜杜勒阿齐兹去中国。
Did you-- when you had that first conversation, did you and your wife fight about it? Were you upset? Were you angry? What was your physical reaction?
当你进行那次第一次谈话时，你和妻子吵架了吗？你难过了吗？你愤怒吗？你的身体反应是什么？
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
I was sad, of course, but I didn't argue or fight with her because she was also on the pressure. On one side she got me and another side her family pressuring her. So I also want to make it easy for her.
我当然很难过，但我没有和她争吵或打架，因为她也承受着压力。一方面她有我，另一方面她家里人在给她施压。所以我也不想让她难做。
Peride said she wanted to go back with the baby just for a short trip, make her parents happy. Then she'd come back with Abduleziz. Abdurahman wasn't crazy about the idea, but he agreed, drove them to the airport.
佩里黛说她想带着孩子回去仅仅做一次短途旅行，让父母高兴。然后她会带阿卜杜勒阿齐兹回来。阿卜杜拉赫曼对这个想法并不疯狂，但他同意了，开车送她们去了机场。
It was hard feeling, but I feel I couldn't do anything else.
感觉很难受，但我感觉我做不了别的。
And so they flew away to go to a place where only fragments of information ever make it out. The plan was that Peride would contact Abdurahman on WeChat once they'd arrived and felt like it was safe, but he didn't hear from them. He called her parents again and again. They never picked up. He started to panic, but this isn't entirely abnormal because of how difficult it is for Uyghurs to communicate with their families in Xinjiang. He was hoping that that was all it was.
于是她们飞向了一个只有信息片段才能流出的地方。原计划是佩里黛到达后一旦觉得安全就会在微信上联系阿卜杜拉赫曼，但他没收到她们的消息。他一次又一次地打电话给她的父母。他们从不接听。他开始恐慌，但这因为维吾尔人与在新疆的家人沟通是多么困难而并不完全异常。他希望仅仅是那样。
After two months of this, he says, a distant relative who was visiting Istanbul on business contacted him and said, let's have lunch. They met. He had news. It wasn't good.
两个月后，他说，一位在伊斯坦布尔出差的远房亲戚联系他，说，一起吃午饭吧。他们见面了。他带来了消息。消息不好。
Police arrested Peride as soon as she and the baby arrived in China. She was interrogated and beaten, the cousin said. She was in prison, serving a 10-year sentence. He thought it was because she lived in Turkey. Human rights observers say they've seen several cases where Uyghurs in Xinjiang have been punished for communicating with people in Turkey or other predominantly Muslim countries. It's not illegal, per se, but it can get you in trouble with the government.
佩里黛一到中国就被警察逮捕了。表亲说，她被审问和殴打。她在监狱里，服刑10年。他认为是因为她住过土耳其。人权观察员说他们见过几起新疆维吾尔人因为与土耳其或其他主要穆斯林国家的人沟通而受到惩罚的案件。这本身不违法，但可能会让你惹上政府麻烦。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
It's like you burn inside, something that's eating you from inside.
就像你在里面燃烧，有什么东西在从内部啃噬着你。
It's eating you from the inside?
它在从内部啃噬你？
Yeah, because you have a lot of pain, but you cannot do anything.
是的，因为你痛苦万分，但你什么也做不了。
Their children are with their grandparents, his in-laws, so at least they're safe. But he can't get his wife out of prison. He can't even call home or try to get more information without endangering his family. Because he's living in Turkey, anyone in Xinjiang who gets a call from him could immediately get flagged by the government. They could be interrogated or even sent to a re-education camp.
他们的孩子和祖父母、他的岳父母在一起，所以至少他们是安全的。但他没法把妻子救出监狱。他甚至没法在不危及家人的情况下打电话回家或尝试获取更多信息。因为他住在土耳其，新疆任何接到他电话的人都可能立即被政府标记。他们可能会被审问，甚至被送往再教育营。
And his family knows this. By this point, most of them have deleted him from their contacts. So he waits. There's nothing he can do. He starts putting on weight. He sleeps late. He's stuck.
他的家人也知道这一点。到这时，他们大多数人已经删除了他的联系方式。所以他在等待。他什么也做不了。他开始发胖。他睡得很晚。他被困住了。
For everything he's gone through, Abdurahman's still pretty young. He's 30. I've known him for about six months now, and he does things all the time that remind me that he's a dad who never got to be a dad. He always brings food when we meet and shares his snacks, like steamed buns with lamb dipped in a spicy vinegar sauce.
经历了一切，阿卜杜拉赫曼还是很年轻。他30岁。我认识他大概六个月了，他总是做一些事提醒我他是一个从未真正成为父亲的父亲。我们见面时他总是带食物分享他的零食，比如蘸着辣醋酱的羊肉蒸包。
Once after an interview, we ran into his friend with her kid at a Uyghur-run cafe. I'll never forget the look on his face while he tossed the toddler up and down in front of the deli cases, this pure, uncomplicated joy. But when I ask him how he feels about all this, he's told me men don't have feelings, which obviously isn't true.
有一次采访后，我们在一家维吾尔人开的咖啡馆遇到了他的朋友和她的孩子。我永远忘不了他隔着熟食柜台把蹒跚学步的孩子抛向空中时脸上那种纯粹、毫无杂念的快乐。但当我问他对此有何感想时，他告诉我男人没有感情，这显然是不真实的。
Back in December of 2018, when Abdurahman was living in Istanbul, hearing nothing from his family, things in Xinjiang were getting worse. More and more Uyghurs were sent to re-education centers and later required to do low wage factory work. Human rights observers say this campaign imprisoned about 10% of Uyghur adults in Xinjiang.
回到2018年12月，当阿卜杜拉赫曼住在伊斯坦布尔，收不到家人的消息时，新疆的情况正在恶化。越来越多的维吾尔人被送往再教育中心，随后被要求从事低工资工厂工作。人权观察员说，这场运动监禁了新疆约10%的维吾尔成年人。
But Abdurahman had no idea what was happening to his family. That's when TikTok came into his life. A friend showed it to him. He was like, you've got to see this.
但阿卜杜拉赫曼根本不知道他的家人发生了什么。那时TikTok走进了他的生活。一个朋友给他看。他就像，你一定要看看这个。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
He said, I just found a relative, a man I know from my hometown. I ask, how do you find people? How does it work? He tells me, you can write the name of your town.
他说，我刚找到一个亲戚，一个我认识的家乡人。我问，你如何找到人？这是如何运作的？他告诉我，你可以写下你城镇的名字。
Abdurahman can't write in Mandarin, so his friend types out the name of his hometown for him. It's called Axu. It's an agricultural center in the west, hugging the mountains that form the border between China, Kyrgyzstan, and Kazakhstan.
阿卜杜拉赫曼不会写中文，所以他的朋友为他输入了他家乡的名字。它叫阿克苏。它是西部的农业中心，环绕着构成中国、吉尔吉斯斯坦和哈萨克斯坦边界的山脉。
Suddenly, hundreds of users are popping up on his screen. He goes through video after video. He sees all of these places that he recognizes-- the woods, and the rivers, and the families hanging out in front of their houses. And he can tell things have definitely changed. The cotton fields look the same. The houses are familiar. But to Abdurahman, Axu looks like a city under occupation.
突然，数百个用户出现在他的屏幕上。他浏览了一个又一个视频。他看到了所有他认出的地方——树林、河流，还有在房前闲逛的家庭。他能看出事情绝对发生了变化。棉田看起来一样。房子很熟悉。但对阿卜杜拉赫曼来说，阿克苏看起来像一座被占领的城市。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
A lot of video is Chinese occupier put on that. And the interviews, it looks like a happy moment to them, but what the video has shown is, for example, a Chinese guy in a Uyghur house. There are only women in the house and a elder lady my mom's age.
很多视频是中国占领者放上去的。还有采访，对他们来说看起来像是一个快乐的时刻，但视频所展示的是，例如，维吾尔家庭里的中国男人。房子里只有女人和一位我妈妈年纪的老太太。
The Chinese man first tried to dance with her, like almost forcing her to dance, and tried to hug her. And the Chinese guys look happy, and they thought they are doing something good, but in our tradition is attack. Like I can see the lady. She cannot do anything against it, but she don't want to dance with the guy.
中国男人先是试图和她跳舞，几乎强迫她跳舞，并试图拥抱她。而中国男人看起来很高兴，他们认为自己在做善事，但在我们的传统里这是一种攻击。就像我能看到那位女士。她对此无能为力，但她不想和那个男人跳舞。
In another video, something else seems off. It's a group of people clearing ice off of an irrigation ditch with picks and shovels. It's winter. You can tell by the trees and the coats they're wearing.
在另一个视频中，有些东西似乎也不对劲。这是一群人正用镐和铁锹清理灌溉渠里的冰。这是冬天。你可以从树木和他们穿的外套看出来。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
Abdurahman knows this ditch. It's just a few minutes from his family's house. And to him, it's clear they're being forced to work. We never clear ice from the ditch until springtime, he tells me. There's no need. It just freezes over again.
阿卜杜拉赫曼认识这条沟渠。离他家人的房子只有几分钟路程。对他来说，很明显他们是被迫工作的。他说，我们从不在春天之前清理沟渠里的冰。根本没必要。它只是会再次冻住。
This watching does not seem to be good for Abdurahman, but he can't stop. TikTok is like this tiny flashlight into the big black box that Xinjiang has become. For a week, he stayed in his apartment just searching. What he was really hoping for was to see someone he recognized, any traces of his kids, his wife's parents, his parents. He hadn't been able to speak to them for several years at this point.
观看这些似乎对阿卜杜拉赫曼没好处，但他停不下来。TikTok就像照进新疆这个巨大黑箱的一盏小手电筒。有一周，他待在公寓里只做搜索。他真正希望的是看到他认识的人，他的孩子、妻子父母、他父母的任何痕迹。到这时他已经几年没能和他们说话了。
He watched at the kitchen table, watched on the couch. At night, he'd lie awake, scrolling. On January 4, 2019, he was in bed, and like usual, scrolling through TikTok. It's around 2:00 AM, and Abdurahman sees this video. It's a little boy with big cheeks, expressive eyes. He's in a school, answering questions in Mandarin Chinese from a teacher off camera. Behind him, kids are milling about in winter coats.
他在厨房桌子上看，在沙发上看。晚上，他躺着清醒，滚动屏幕。2019年1月4日，他在床上，像往常一样滚动TikTok。大约是凌晨2点，阿卜杜拉赫曼看到了这个视频。是一个有着大脸颊、富有表情眼睛的小男孩。他在学校里，正在回答画外音老师用汉语提出的问题。在他身后，孩子们穿着冬装走来走去。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[汉语]
They have a leather jacket, winter jacket.
他们穿着皮夹克、冬夹克。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[汉语]
The teacher asks the kid a bunch of questions. What's the name of the fatherland? The People's Republic of China. What's on the fatherland's flag? Five stars on a red flag. Where's your water bottle? Water bottle is here. Where do we put the food we can't finish? In the trash.
老师问孩子一堆问题。祖国的名字是什么？中华人民共和国。祖国旗帜上有什么？红旗上的五颗星。你的水瓶在哪里？水瓶在这里。吃不完的食物我们放在哪儿？垃圾桶里。
Abdurahman doesn't speak Mandarin, but there is one word that stands out to him, Abduleziz. What's your name, the teacher asks? I'm called Abduleziz, he says. How old are you? I'm four. That's how old Abdurahman's son should be now.
阿卜杜拉赫曼不会说汉语，但有一个词对他来说很突出，阿卜杜勒阿齐兹。你叫什么名字，老师问？我叫阿卜杜勒阿齐兹，他说。你多大了？我四岁。那是阿卜杜拉赫曼的儿子现在应该有的岁数。
The video is just 15 seconds long, one of a hundred that he's watched that day, and he can't be sure it's his son, Abduleziz. But Abdurahman simultaneously gets this rush of love believing that it's his son and this intense fear that it's really him. Because his kids are supposed to be living with their grandparents while he figures out a way to get them home. And it looks like they aren't.
视频只有15秒长，他那天看过的一百个中的一个，他不能确定那是不是他的儿子阿卜杜勒阿齐兹。但阿卜杜拉赫曼同时感受到一股相信那是他儿子的爱的冲击，和它是真的那种强烈的恐惧。因为他的孩子应该和祖父母住在一起，而他在想办法让他们回家。看起来他们没有。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
As soon as I see it, I can feel it's a camp for children.
我一看到它，我就能感觉到这是一个儿童营。
It looks like Abduleziz is in a boarding school, one of the ones set up by the Chinese government to take care of about 500,000 kids, many of whose parents have been detained in re-education camps. Except for short visits home, the kids are generally kept away from their family, taught Mandarin, not Uyghur.
看起来阿卜杜勒阿齐兹在寄宿学校，中国政府为照顾约50万名儿童建立的学校之一，其中许多孩子的父母被关押在再教育营中。除了短暂的回国探亲，孩子们通常与家人保持距离，学习汉语，而不是维吾尔语。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
Yeah, I feel that my son is becoming more Chinese every day. After I understood the video, I became worried about his future, how the regime will teach him and make him an enemy of Uyghurs in the future, especially make him an enemy of people like me.
是的，我觉得我儿子变得越来越像中国人。明白视频后，我开始担心他的未来，政权将如何教导他并使他未来成为维吾尔人的敌人，特别是使他成为像我这样的人的敌人。
That seems to be exactly the point of these schools. They place these kids in a setting where they're removed from their families, their language, their religion, their Uyghurness. As one internal government document claims, the goal of this crackdown is to, quote, "break their lineage, break their roots, break their connections, and break their origins." The government is their family now.
这似乎正是这些学校的目的。他们把这些孩子安置在一个让他们与家人、语言、宗教和“维吾尔性”脱离的环境中。正如一份内部政府文件所称，这次镇压的目标是，“切断他们的血缘，切断他们的根源，切断他们的连接，切断他们的起源”。政府现在就是他们的家人。
From this moment, when Abdurahman saw his son in this video, all he wanted was to get him back. He was consumed by it. I should say there are lots of parents around the world in the same situation. In the past year or so, I've personally spoken to nine of them in three different countries. Only one was able to get her son out of China, thanks to an influential family member and a Turkish passport. Still, Abdurahman was convinced that he, a guy who doesn't speak Mandarin, doesn't have political connections, can't even call home, he was going to get his son back.
从这一刻起，当阿卜杜拉赫曼在视频中看到他的儿子时，他想要的只是把他救回来。他为此消耗殆尽。我应该说全世界有很多处于同样情况的父母。过去一年左右，我亲自在三个不同国家与其中九个人交谈过。只有一个人成功救出了她的儿子，多亏了一位有影响力的亲戚和一本土耳其护照。尽管如此，阿卜杜拉赫曼还是坚信他，一个不会说汉语、没有政治联系、甚至没法打电话回家的家伙，他要把儿子救回来。
Reporter Durrie Bouscaren. Coming up, Abdurahman uses everything he has to get his family back. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
记者杜里·布斯卡伦。即将到来，阿卜杜拉赫曼用尽他所有的一切来接回他的家人。那是在节目继续后的芝加哥公共广播电台一分钟后。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Black Box, stories of people who don't have the information they need and want, trying to figure out what's going on and what they should do next. We now continue with Act One of our show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《黑箱》，讲述的是那些没有他们需要的信息的人的故事，试图弄清楚发生了什么以及他们下一步该做什么。我们现在继续节目的第一幕。
Right before the break, maybe you heard Abdurahman Tohti thought that he spotted his four-year-old son on a TikTok video and decided to set out on a mission to retrieve him and the rest of his family. Reporter Durrie Bouscaren picks up with Abdurahman's story.
在节目前，也许你听到了阿卜杜拉赫曼·托赫蒂以为他在TikTok视频上发现了四岁的儿子，并决定开始一项接回他和其余家人的任务。记者杜里·布斯卡伦接续阿卜杜拉赫曼的故事。
The first thing he did was he went to the press, made it public. This was risky because his family was still in China. His interviews were published all over the world in Turkish, English, Portuguese. He was on the BBC and in The New York Times.
他做的第一件事是联系媒体，公开此事。这是有风险的，因为他的家人还在中国。他的采访在世界各地以土耳其语、英语、葡萄牙语出版。他在BBC和《纽约时报》上出现过。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
The media attention was so intense in the beginning. That makes me have more hope and trust. I think, OK, something maybe will happen. But then I find out it will not happen.
媒体的关注度在最初非常强烈。这让我有了更多的希望和信任。我想，好吧，也许会发生什么。但后来我发现它不会发生。
With each of these interviews, it felt like he was screaming into the void, trying to get China and the world to look at him. And the response, silence. He was no closer to getting his family back than he was when they left.
每一次采访，都感觉像是在向虚空呐喊，试图让中国和世界看着他。而回应是沉默。他距离接回家人并没有比他们离开时更近。
He tried more official routes. He went to the Chinese embassy, nothing, asked the Turkish government for help, wrote to the United Nations. He once told me about this plan to move to Canada as a refugee because he thought the government there would have more leverage. Mind you, that would take years to come to fruition. But he truly believes that one day his family will be together again.
他尝试了更正式的途径。他去了中国大使馆，什么都没有，请求土耳其政府帮助，写信给联合国。他曾经告诉过我作为难民搬到加拿大的计划，因为他认为那里的政府会有更多筹码。提醒一下，那需要几年才能实现。但他真心相信有一天他的家人会再次团聚。
He has these pictures on his phone. Because there's no portrait of his family, he's made some using passport photos of him and Peride, a baby picture he has of his daughter, and a screenshot of that video of Abduleziz. They're Photoshopped onto backgrounds, the cathedral of Notre Dame in Paris, cherry blossoms in Japan.
他的手机里有这些照片。因为没有全家福，他用他和佩里黛的护照照片、一张他女儿的婴儿照，以及阿卜杜勒阿齐兹那段视频的截图制作了一些。它们被PS到各种背景上，巴黎圣母院大教堂，日本的樱花。
So why do you do that? Can you tell me about that?
那么你为什么这样做？你能告诉我关于这个吗？
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
It's because we're a family, he tells me. Last summer, Abdurahman had some luck. He was scrolling through WeChat, and he found a childhood friend. He says they hatched a plan to buy a plane ticket for her to go back to their hometown, get eyes on the ground. But, of course, even when she made it all the way there and was sending him videos of their old neighborhood, she still couldn't speak directly to what she was actually seeing, the significance of it.
是因为我们是一个家庭，他告诉我。去年夏天，阿卜杜拉赫曼运气不错。他在滚动微信时，找到了一个儿时朋友。他说他们制定了一个计划，为她买一张机票回他们的家乡，进行实地考察。但当然，即使她一路到达那里并向他发送了旧街区的视频，她仍然没法直接说出她实际上看到的东西，以及它的意义。
Everything's fine, she told him. Everything's new and better, as she panned the camera around the empty streets. Abdurahman was kicked off WeChat, so we don't have the actual videos. And we weren't able to reach his friend without risking her safety. But he says the way she spoke was super casual to avoid drawing attention.
一切都很好，她告诉他。一切都是新的且更好的，她转动镜头扫过空荡荡的街道。阿卜杜拉赫曼被踢出了微信，所以我们没有实际的视频。我们没能在不危及她安全的情况下联系到他的朋友。但他说她说话的方式超级随意，为了避免引起注意。
The buildings are not here anymore. Don't get surprised because they have built new restaurants here. If you come here, I will buy food for you-- like basically joking. And then I answer her, why should I be surprised? OK, maybe one day we have a chance to meet there.
这些建筑已经不在这里了。别感到惊讶，因为他们在这里盖了新餐馆。如果你来这里，我会请你吃饭——基本上是在开玩笑。然后我回答她，我为什么要惊讶？好吧，也许有一天我们有机会在那里见面。
She drove to the street his parents lived on. There were a lot of checkpoints. Eventually she got there and found an empty lot. His family's house in the city had been demolished. They have another home, a farm. They could have moved there.
她开车到他父母住的那条街。有很多检查站。最终她到了那里，发现了一块空地。他家在市里的房子已经被拆除了。他们有另一处房产，一个农场。他们可能搬到那儿了。
But this is the point when Abdurahman started to worry that his parents had been taken too. He hadn't been able to speak to them in four years. Every time he gets more information, it's like this. The more he learns, the worse things seem.
但这是阿卜杜拉赫曼开始担心他的父母也被带走的时候。他已经四年没能和他们说话了。每次他获得更多信息，都是这样。他了解的越多，情况似乎越糟。
Abdurahman still watches TikTok. It's like a nervous habit when he's bored, when he's tired. In interviews, when it takes too long for an interpreter to translate a question, he'll sort of lean back and pull his phone out from under the table.
阿卜杜拉赫曼仍然观看TikTok。当他无聊、疲惫时，这就像一种神经质的习惯。在采访中，当口译员翻译一个问题花太长时间时，他会稍微后仰，从桌子下拿出手机。
Eventually in January of this year, the app shook loose another piece of information. An old acquaintance wrote to him through TikTok's direct messaging function. The messages start off nonchalantly enough. Hi, how are you, brother? Abdurahman asked him if he's seen his parents lately. How are they doing?
最终在今年1月，应用程序松动了另一条信息。一个老熟人通过TikTok的私信功能写信给他。消息开始得很随意。嗨，你好吗，兄弟？阿卜杜拉赫曼问他是否最近见过他的父母。他们怎么样？
The friend didn't have any information about his son or his wife, but he could tell Abdurahman that his family in Axu is gone. They're not staying at their farm like he had hoped. His elderly father, his mother who has cancer, he gives them name after name. They're gone. They're gone too.
朋友没有关于他儿子或妻子的任何信息，但他能告诉阿卜杜拉赫曼他在阿克苏的家人不见了。他们没有像他希望的那样待在农场。他年迈的父亲，患癌症的母亲，他一个接一个地报出名字。他们不见了。他们也不见了。
And Abdurahman can't even be sure what this means. They could have been forced off their land but living elsewhere. They could be detained in a re-education center. They could be in prison. From thousands of miles away, it's almost impossible to find out.
而阿卜杜拉赫曼甚至没法确定这意味着什么。他们可能被迫离开土地但住在别处。他们可能被关在再教育中心。他们可能在监狱里。从几千英里外，几乎不可能找出真相。
As he's telling me this, it's the day after he got these messages. And Abdurahman is getting really worked up. He's talking super, super fast, like a dam has burst and all of these emotions from the past three years are spilling over.
当他告诉我这个时，是他收到这些消息的第二天。阿卜杜拉赫曼变得非常激动。他说话速度超级快，就像水坝决堤，过去三年里的所有情绪都涌了出来。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
Not only my parents. My parents, brothers, sisters, all of them are gone.
不仅仅是我的父母。我的父母、兄弟、姐妹，他们所有人都消失了。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
They have taken-- they have taken everything from me-- property, land, family, son, wife. Everything I got in my life they have taken from me. I'm ready to do anything I can to take revenge.
他们带走了——他们从我这里带走了一切——财产、土地、家人、儿子、妻子。我生命中得到的一切他们都从我这里夺走了。我准备好做任何我能做的来报复。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
So officials in Chinese embassy, I will smash their cars, smash their buildings until they arrest me or they put my parents free. What can I else do? I've got enough with just speaking empty words.
所以中国大使馆的官员，我会砸烂他们的汽车，砸烂他们的建筑，直到他们逮捕我或者释放我的父母。我还能做什么？我受够了仅仅说空话。
Throw me in jail, keep me outside, it's no different, he says. They've killed my soul. I have nothing to live for anymore.
把我扔进监狱，把我关在外面，没有区别，他说。他们杀死了我的灵魂。我再也没有什么可活的了。
We later called the local police station in his hometown and confirmed that no one is at his family's address, even though 13 people used to live there. They knew that Abdurahman was looking for his family and put a Uyghur speaker on the line to talk to him. Maybe they've left. Maybe they did something wrong, the speaker said, but she refused to say if they were accused of a crime.
我们后来拨打了家乡当地的派出所，证实了他家人的地址处没有人，尽管过去有13个人住在那里。他们知道阿卜杜拉赫曼在找他的家人，安排了一名讲维吾尔语的人在线上与他交谈。也许他们走了。也许他们做错了什么，对方说，但她拒绝说明他们是否被指控犯罪。
Two days after he gets to the news about his family, he found something new to fixate on, the mayor of Istanbul. He thought that if he could convince this guy to help him, he might be able to put in a word to Turkish diplomats who help people detained overseas. The mayor was scheduled to speak at an afternoon event, a dinner in honor of the different cultures of the Turkic world, like the Turks, the Uzbeks, and the Uyghurs.
在收到家人消息的两天后，他找到了新的关注点，伊斯坦布尔市长。他认为如果能说服这家伙帮他，也许能向土耳其外交官说句话，帮助那些在海外被拘留的人。市长计划在下午的活动上发言，一个纪念突厥世界不同文化（如土耳其人、乌兹别克人和维吾尔人）的晚宴。
I met up with him to go there. He's brought bags of Uyghur breads and fried noodles for the event because an activist told him it might help him get a chance to meet with the mayor face to face. The chances of this resulting in anything are slim. Honestly, it's a Hail Mary.
我和他见面一起去那里。他带来了几袋维吾尔面包和炒面参加活动，因为一位活动人士告诉他这也许能帮他获得与市长面对面见面的机会。这导致任何结果的机会很小。老实说，这是一次“万福玛利亚”式的尝试。
But as down as Abdurahman was the day before, he's up now, buzzing with excitement in the car on the way over.
但正如前一天阿卜杜拉赫曼很沮丧，他现在情绪高涨，在去的车里兴奋得嗡嗡作响。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
I'm going there as a human being and asking them to do their duty as a human being, he tells me. The event is happening outside a museum under a big tent. Abdurahman pulls his bags of food out of the car, and we wait for the mayor.
我作为一个人类去那里，请求他们履行作为人类的职责，他告诉我。活动在博物馆外的一个大帐篷下举行。阿卜杜拉赫曼把食物袋从车里拿出来，我们等着市长。
A few minutes turns into a few hours. He falls back into his phone, flipping through TikTok videos like usual. He looks tired. Finally, just as the program is about to begin, the mayor sweeps in with bodyguards in tow. He's introduced, ushered onto the stage, and he speaks for about 15 minutes.
几分钟变成了几小时。他退回到手机里，像往常一样翻阅TikTok视频。他看起来很累。终于，就在节目即将开始时，市长带着保镖涌入。他被介绍，被引领上台，他发言了大约15分钟。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语演说]
And then the mayor moves to leave. Abdurahman realizes that this is his chance. He needs to go now. But a group of admirers descends on the mayor, shaking his hand, giving him gifts. Abdurahman waits on the edge, hanging back, until he sees an opening and makes his move. I stand back with our interpreter to watch.
然后市长起身离开。阿卜杜拉赫曼意识到这是他的机会。他现在必须走了。但一群仰慕者涌向市长，握手，送礼。阿卜杜拉赫曼等在边缘，退缩着，直到他看到空隙并开始行动。我和我们的口译员站在后面看。
I see him going up.
我看到他上去了。
Yeah, and there are bodyguards.
是的，还有保镖。
He's like the one green sweater in a sea of moving black suits. He's trying. He's so close. He's so close. He just wants to shake his hand.
他就像在移动的黑色西装海洋里那件绿色毛衣。他在努力。他离得很近。他离得很近。他只是想握个手。
He disappears into the crowd. And just as the mayor is leaving the tent, he's able to wiggle through to get close enough to greet him. They shake hands. It's just enough time to say hello, not to explain a story or to ask for help to find his son. And the mayor moves on. It's the same as every other time he's reached out to the Turkish government for help. Nothing changes.
他消失在人群中。就在市长离开帐篷时，他能够挤过去靠近打招呼。他们握手了。只有足够打个招呼的时间，没法解释故事或请求帮助寻找他的儿子。而市长走开了。这和他每次联系土耳其政府求助都一样。什么都没改变。
We sent requests for comment to China's Ministry of Foreign Affairs, Ministry of Public Security, and Ministry of Education, asking for information about Abdurahman's family. No response. We tried the Office of the Vice President of the Xinjiang Autonomous Region and the local propaganda department. In that case, someone did pick up, told us their fax machine was broken and that no other fax machines were available.
我们向中国外交部、公安部和教育部发送了评论请求，询问关于阿卜杜拉赫曼家人的信息。没有回应。我们尝试了新疆自治区副主席办公室和当地宣传部门。在那个案子里，确实有人接听，告诉我们他们的传真机坏了，没有其他传真机可用。
So we summarized the questions over the phone. The person on the other end called it sheer nonsense and told us to go online and read the news. The Chinese embassy in Washington, DC basically said the same thing. I asked for information on Abdurahman's family and on these cases in general.
所以我们通过电话总结了问题。电话那头的人称这纯属无稽之谈，并告诉我们要上网看新闻。华盛顿特区的中国大使馆基本上说了同样的话。我要求获取关于阿卜杜拉赫曼家人及这些案件的总体信息。
They responded with a list of YouTube links, videos posted by China's state media service, defending the re-education camp program and claiming that people who say their families have been imprisoned are lying. I would suggest you check some of the rumors being exposed, they wrote. Thanks for reaching out to the embassy.
他们回应了一串YouTube链接，中国国家媒体服务发布的视频，为再教育营计划辩护，并声称说家人被监禁的人在撒谎。他们写道：“我建议你看看一些被揭露的谣言。谢谢你联系大使馆。”
We also can't reach Peride. We confirmed as many details as we could about Peride and Abdurahman's life together with a friend of theirs. It took more than a year before Abdurahman finally saw a small glimmer of success. Weirdly, it was the pandemic that did it.
我们也无法联系到佩里黛。我们与他们的一位朋友确认了尽可能多的关于佩里黛和阿卜杜拉赫曼共同生活的细节。花了一年多时间，阿卜杜拉赫曼才终于看到了微弱的成功曙光。奇怪的是，是疫情做到了这一点。
This winter, news of the coronavirus outbreak in Wuhan started to filter out of China. The videos Abdurahman started to see on TikTok were of empty streets, people stuck at home without much to eat. Some would set their videos to music pulled from zombie movies. Abdurahman began to worry about Xinjiang. Social distancing is happening there, but the Uyghurs in prison don't have that option.
今年冬天，武汉新冠疫情的消息开始从中国传出。阿卜杜拉赫曼开始在TikTok上看到的视频是空荡荡的街道，人们被困在家里没有太多食物。有些人把他们的视频配上从丧尸电影里提取的音乐。阿卜杜拉赫曼开始担心新疆。那里正在发生社会隔离，但监狱里的维吾尔人没得选。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
Somebody gets infected amongst the prisoners or somebody in camp, then all of them will be infected. So I'm worried.
如果囚犯中有人被感染或营地里有人被感染，那么他们所有人都会被感染。所以我很担心。
And it's not just the people in prison. People detained in re-education centers can also get infected or the kids who have been separated from their parents and placed in government schools. So this winter, a group of parents in Istanbul started planning a trip to the Chinese embassy, to show up in person and demand access to their children. Before anything was finalized, the parents started to get phone calls from the consulate. Abdurahman got one too.
而不仅仅是监狱里的人。被拘留在再教育中心的人也可能被感染，或者那些被与父母分离并安置在政府学校的孩子。所以今年冬天，伊斯坦布尔的一群父母开始策划去中国大使馆的行程，亲自到场并要求获得探望孩子的许可。在一切敲定之前，父母们开始接到领事馆的电话。阿卜杜拉赫曼也接到了一个。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
It was last Friday. I came out from the Friday prayer.
是上周五。我做完周五祷告出来。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
I was driving and transporting something to [NON-ENGLISH]. And I got a phone call while I'm driving. It was an Uyghur. He said, I have good news for you.
我在开车并运送东西到[非英语]。开车时我接到了一个电话。是个维吾尔人。他说，我有好消息告诉你。
The caller was a translator for the Chinese consulate. He had information about Abdurahman's children, he said. Your kids are with their uncle, the caller told him, not in a boarding school. They're safe.
打电话的人是中国领事馆的翻译。他说他有关于阿卜杜拉赫曼孩子的信息。打电话的人告诉他，你的孩子和他们的叔叔在一起，不在寄宿学校。他们很安全。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
OK, which uncle is that? And the guy said, I don't know. So I said, OK, let's meet. Where are you?
好的，是哪个叔叔？那家伙说，我不知道。所以我说，好吧，让我们见个面。你在哪？
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
And he said, no, we don't have to meet. This is the only news I have.
他说，不，我们不需要见面。这是我唯一的消息。
He got this call in March. He still has no idea if it was true or not. This drop of information, an unprovable bit of news that he desperately wants to hear, it could be a lie designed to placate, keep him quiet. He knows this.
他在3月接到这个电话。他仍然不知道那是真是假。这一点点信息，他迫切想听到的未经证实的一条消息，可能是一个旨在平息事态、让他安静的谎言。他知道这一点。
But Abdurahman insists that even if it's not true, it's still good news. What this phone call means to him is that now someone in the government has finally acknowledged his jumping, and screaming, and waving his hands. Someone somewhere might actually be responding.
但阿卜杜拉赫曼坚持认为，即使这不是真的，依然是好消息。这个电话对他来说意味着终于有政府里的人承认了他的跳跃、尖叫和挥动手臂。某处的某个人可能真的在回应。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
This is good news, but until I see them directly, I will fight for their case.
这是好消息，但在我直接见到他们之前，我会为他们的案子而战。
Until you see a video or until you see them here in Turkey?
直到你看到视频，或者直到你在土耳其见到他们？
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
Until I get them to Turkey.
直到我把他们接到土耳其。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
It's about-- I meet my son and I start to take care of them as a father. I will not stop. For me, it's good news. It gives me hope.
那是关于——我见到了儿子，我开始以父亲的身份照顾他们。我不会停止。对我来说，这是好消息。它给了我希望。
Abdurahman has renewed hope that they'll be together again. Because this time, after four years of trying to find his family, the black box has spoken back. But even this tiny victory is short lived.
阿卜杜拉赫曼重新燃起了他们再次团聚的希望。因为这一次，在尝试寻找家人四年后，黑箱有了回应。但即使是这个微小的胜利也短暂。
A month later, Abdurahman calls me from the road. He's driving, balancing the phone on the steering wheel.
一个月后，阿卜杜拉赫曼从路上给我打电话。他在开车，电话平衡在方向盘上。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
He says a contact from TikTok who's been sending him information about Axu wrote to him to tell him that local government officials went on the village loudspeaker to make a public announcement saying anyone with information about the Tohti family, Abdurahman's family, is forbidden to share it.
他说一位通过TikTok发送阿克苏信息的消息来源写信告诉他，当地政府官员通过村里的扬声器发布了公告，称禁止任何拥有关于托赫蒂家族（阿卜杜拉赫曼家人）信息的人分享。
[SPEAKING UYGHUR]
[维吾尔语]
Look, we are now living in 21st century. And if people lose their cats or their dogs, they will have a right to look for them. In my case, of course, I have a right to get information about my family, as a father, as a son, but they are even forbidding me to get any information about my family members.
看，我们现在生活在21世纪。如果人们丢了猫或狗，他们有权寻找它们。在我的情况下，当然，作为父亲、作为儿子，我有权获得关于我家人的信息，但他们甚至禁止我获取任何关于我家人的信息。
His fear is that they are going to disappear. There would be no charges, no prison sentence, no anticipated date of their release, no communication with the outside world. And he'll never know what became of them.
他的恐惧是他们会消失。没有指控，没有刑期，没有预期的释放日期，没有与外界的通讯。他永远不会知道他们发生了什么。
And what frustrates him is that right now people he knows are starting to hear news of what's happening to their families, that they've moved out of re-education centers and into low wage factory work or formal prison sentences. They're getting answers, but Abdurahman still knows nothing. For years, he's been fighting for information. He may never get it.
让他沮丧的是，现在他认识的人开始听到他们家人发生的事情的消息，比如他们已经从再教育中心搬到了低工资工厂工作或正式刑期中。他们得到了答案，但阿卜杜拉赫曼依然什么都不知道。多年来，他一直在为信息而战。他可能永远得不到。
Durrie Bouscaren in Istanbul.
伊斯坦布尔的杜里·布斯卡伦。
Act Two, State of Emergency. So our show today is about people trying to find their way in situations where they don't have much information, or anyway the information they need. And, of course, that's the situation the whole world is in right now with the spread of COVID-19 as we try to make sense of how to treat it, how to deal with it as a society.
第二幕，紧急状态。我们今天的节目是关于人们试图在没有多少信息，或者无论如何没有他们需要信息的情况下寻找出路，当然，这也是全世界现在面对新冠疫情传播时所处的情况，当我们试图理解如何治疗它，如何作为社会处理它时。
Couple weeks ago, my co-worker Miki Meek talked to one emergency medical worker in Brooklyn, Anthony Almojera. He's vice president of local 3621 of the EMS Officers Union in New York City. EMS, emergency medical services-- it's part of the fire department. Even a few weeks ago, they were totally overwhelmed. Anthony was out responding to an endless stream of 911 calls.
几周前，我的同事米基·米克与布鲁克林的紧急医疗工作者安东尼·阿尔莫杰拉谈过。他是纽约市EMS官员工会3621分会的副主席。EMS，紧急医疗服务——它是消防局的一部分。甚至几周前，他们还完全不堪重负。安东尼一直在回应无休止的911呼叫。
And Miki checked back in with him recently to see how he's doing. He said that even though the number of infections in the city has finally started to slow, his crew is still in uncharted territory. And a lot of the calls they're getting are for cardiac arrest. Apparently the virus, in addition to attacking the lungs, can also put stress on the heart and sometimes directly infect the heart.
米基最近回访了他，看看他怎么样。他说，即使城市里的感染人数终于开始放缓，他的团队仍处于未知的境地。他们接到的很多电话都是关于心脏骤停的。显然，病毒除了攻击肺部，还会给心脏带来压力，有时直接感染心脏。
Some days, the number of cardiac arrest calls coming into New York City's 911 system has been huge, over 300. It's about four times higher than before the pandemic. Most of those people are dying at home. Here's Miki talking to Anthony and then to one of his colleagues.
有些日子，纽约市911系统收到的心脏骤停电话数量巨大，超过300个。比大流行前高出约四倍。大多数人死在家里。这是米基和安东尼以及他的一位同事交谈。
Anthony, how are you doing?
安东尼，你好吗？
I'm OK, I guess. It's still crazy. This past Sunday, I did 13 cardiac arrests in a 16-hour shift.
我还好，我想。还是疯了。上周日，我在16小时的班次里处理了13起心脏骤停。
Jeez, 13.
天哪，13起。
13.
13起。
13 cardiac arrests-- what does that day look like for you?
13起心脏骤停——那一天对你来说是什么样的？
So I wake up. I put the uniform on. I'm sitting there, trying to mentally get myself geared up for another day of this.
所以我醒来。我穿上制服。我坐在那里，试图在心理上为又一天这样的日子做好准备。
I get a Red Bull. If you're going to be in the middle of hell, you might as well be alert. And I'm going to work, and my brain is sitting there-- it's weird because my brain is sitting there going, OK, I got to get ready because I know it's coming. Then it starts coming. 6:30 in the morning, it started coming.
我喝了一罐红牛。如果你要身处地狱之中，最好保持警觉。我去上班，大脑坐在那里——很奇怪，因为我的大脑坐在那里想，“好吧，我得准备好，因为我知道它要来了”。然后它开始来了。早上6:30，它就开始来了。
I go. Elderly gentleman-- fever, cough, symptoms. We try and work him up. We were unsuccessful. I tell the family, I'm sorry. There's nothing more we can do.
我去了。老绅士——发烧、咳嗽、症状。我们试图救治他。我们没成功。我告诉家人，我很抱歉。我们无能为力了。
And then I go back into the truck. I hit the button. I get called for the other cardiac arrests. And I go, another family, the patient's family saying that he had a cough for five days and he was weak with chills. We try and work him up, we're unsuccessful. We pronounce.
然后我回到救护车。我按下按钮。我被叫去处理其他心脏骤停。我去处理，另一个家庭，病人的家属说他咳嗽了五天，身体虚弱且畏寒。我们试图救治，没成功。我们宣布死亡。
I hit the button. I get hit again for another cardiac arrest. I go. This particular patient we weren't able to work up because he had rigor mortis, so he had been dead for a little while.
我按下按钮。我再次因为另一起心脏骤停被叫到。我去处理。这个特定的病人我们无法救治，因为他有尸僵，所以他已经死了一段时间了。
But the family states, oh, he had fever, cough symptoms. So we were like, OK. I'm sorry for your loss. There's another one that happened today. I'm sorry for your loss.
但家人说，哦，他有发烧、咳嗽症状。所以我们就说，好的。很抱歉你的损失。今天发生了另一件。很抱歉你的损失。
And then the next call-- and this is going to sound weird to the everyday person, but the next call was a suicide. There's no fever, cough. So it's like, oh, a regular call, so to speak, as opposed to having to get all crazy with the gowns, and the gloves, and the masks. It's such a morbid scene, but there's three of us that are like, well, this is one patient we don't have to worry about getting this virus from. And it's like, to feel relief in the middle of this tragic death-- I mean, this is somebody who felt hopeless enough to go and commit suicide. We still have the empathy for him and whatnot, but hey, we're going to get through this one without getting infected by anything.
然后下一个呼叫——这对普通人来说听起来很奇怪，但下一个呼叫是自杀。没有发烧、咳嗽。所以就像，哦，一个常规呼叫，可以说，而不是像以前那样必须疯狂地穿着长袍、戴手套和口罩。这是一个多么病态的场景，但我们三个人觉得，好吧，这是我们不用担心感染这种病毒的一位病人。这就像，在这一悲惨死亡中间感到宽慰——我的意思是，这是一个感到绝望到去自杀的人。我们仍然对他有同情心之类的，但嘿，我们这一趟不用感染任何东西就能挺过来。
And then I hit the button. The button shows that I'm available. And I'm on my way to another cardiac arrest.
然后我按下按钮。按钮显示我空闲。我在去另一起心脏骤停的路上。
I've never had a panic or an anxiety attack, and I feel like one is going to come on really soon.
我从来没经历过恐慌或焦虑发作，我觉得很快就要来一次了。
This is another paramedic in New York City I'm calling Cassandra. She didn't want me to use her real name because she didn't get permission from the fire department to talk to me. I've been checking in with her regularly over the past few weeks, and she's processing her days differently than Anthony.
这是纽约市的另一位护理人员，我叫她卡桑德拉。她不想让我用她的真名，因为她没得到消防局的许可与我交谈。过去几周我一直与她定期联系，她处理日子方式与安东尼不同。
Because she's not a lieutenant, she spends her entire 12-hour day in an ambulance. I talked to her recently after she'd finished one of her shifts. She'd gotten home at 3:00 AM and took a bubble bath to try and calm down, but it didn't work.
因为她不是中尉，她在救护车上度过整个12小时的一天。我最近在她结束一个班次后与她谈过。她在凌晨3点到家，泡了个泡泡浴试图冷静下来，但没用。
How much more worse than this can it get? We're at worst to me. This is my worst. I did 37 cardiac arrests last week. I told somebody I'm sorry for your loss 37 times last week.
这还会坏到什么程度？对我来说这已经是最坏了。我上周处理了37起心脏骤停。我上周告诉别人37次“很抱歉你的损失”。
37 times I'm sorry for your loss.
37次很抱歉你的损失。
Yeah. And-- yeah. I don't think I've ever done that in a year, like 37 cardiac arrests. That's insane to me. I don't even know how to explain it. Like, my soul hurts. I'm not used to seeing all this death all at once.
是的。而且——是的。我不认为我一年里做过那么多，比如37起心脏骤停。这对我来说太疯狂了。我甚至不知道如何解释它。我的灵魂很痛。我不习惯一次性看到所有这些死亡。
I'm a person. I'm very strong headed. So it's just like, if I see death it's like, OK, this happened. I process it quick. And I'm like, I deliver my message to the family.
我是一个人。我意志很坚强。所以就像，如果我看到死亡，就像，好的，这发生了。我很快处理它。就像，我向家人传达我的消息。
And it's like, damn, that was messed up. And I move on. It's not like it sticks with me for a while. And right now that's not the case. I'm holding each and every one of them in because I don't have time to just put it away.
然后就像，该死，那真糟糕。然后我继续前进。不像它会粘在我身上一段时间。而现在不是那样。我把每一个都记在心里，因为我没时间把它放下一边。
I was wondering, are there any particular calls that stick with you right now?
我在想，现在有特别粘在你身上的呼叫吗？
There was actually one cardiac arrest that I had last week that wasn't COVID related. But the guy was 107 years old, and he was fighting. He really wanted to live. And I was shocked at that.
实际上上周我有一起心脏骤停，不是新冠相关的。但那个人107岁了，他在战斗。他真的想活下去。我对此感到震惊。
And that made me a little bit happy because I thought we were going to get him back. We didn't. We pronounced him at the end, but he was fighting. He really wanted to live.
这让我稍微有点高兴，因为我以为我们要把他救回来了。我们没能。最后我们宣布死亡，但他一直在战斗。他真的想活下去。
What do you fear most right now? Like, what's the fear that's on your mind this morning?
你现在最怕什么？比如，今天早上你脑子里有什么恐惧？
I'm a ticking bomb. If I don't start dealing with stuff, I'm going to blow up on my partner or on somebody. And God forbid that's on a patient because I don't want to be mean to somebody that just lost a loved one, you know what I mean? I don't know how I'm going to react to not dealing with all this death constantly.
我是一枚定时炸弹。如果我不开始处理这些事情，我会在我的搭档或某人身上爆发。上帝保佑那不是对着病人，因为我不想对刚刚失去亲人的人刻薄，你知道我的意思吗？我不知道我会如何反应，如果我不不断处理所有这些死亡的话。
Do you have a plan?
你有计划吗？
I don't. I don't have time to make a plan.
没有。我没时间制定计划。
Anthony, when I talked to you last, it was very hard having to deliver news to people and not being able to comfort them, having to keep a distance. And so I talked to you about a little over two weeks ago. And I'm wondering, has that gotten easier for you? Have you readjusted?
安东尼，上次我和你谈话时，必须向人们传达坏消息而无法安慰他们、必须保持距离真的很难。所以我在大约两周多前和你谈过。我想知道，这对你来说变容易了吗？你调整过来了吗？
No, it's not easier. And to be honest with you, I don't want it to be easy. If it gets easy to me, that means maybe I'm suffering from a little emotional fatigue, I'm burning out.
不，没容易。老实说，我不想它变容易。如果对我来说变容易了，那就意味着也许我正遭受一点情感疲劳，我快耗尽了。
If I still feel sadness, that's a good thing. I mean, it sucks, but it's a good thing. It means I'm still feeling. In my head, I try to remember that the sun does come out the next day. And I know that sounds corny, but it's awfully cloudy at the moment.
如果我仍然感到悲伤，那是件好事。我的意思是，这很糟糕，但这是件好事。这意味着我仍然有感觉。在我脑子里，我试着记住太阳第二天会出来。我知道这听起来很老套，但此刻确实阴云密布。
Yeah.
是的。
But the thing that's hard about this is, as a medic, you are eternally hopeful in the face of fighting death every day. Because even if you didn't get them this time, you know that the next time you will. But this virus out here, this pandemic, we're not getting them next time.
但这件事难点在于，作为医务人员，你在每天对抗死亡面前永远充满希望。因为即使你这次没救回来，你知道下一次你会。但外面的这种病毒，这种流行病，我们下次救不回他们。
Right now about 15% of the emergency medical service workers for the New York Fire Department are out on sick leave. At least three are in the ICU on ventilators. And one longtime worker, a watch commander in downtown Brooklyn named Greg Hodge, died earlier this week from COVID. Anthony took this news hard. He says Greg is the one who trained him when he first came on the job.
目前纽约消防局紧急医疗服务工作人员中约15%的人在请病假。至少有三人在重症监护室插着呼吸机。一位长期工作者，在布鲁克林市中心担任观察指挥官的格雷格·霍奇，本周早些时候死于新冠。安东尼对这个消息深受打击。他说格雷格是他刚入职时培训他的人。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our show. Just a program note after that story-- if you or somebody you know might need help, the National Suicide Prevention Lifeline is available 24/7 at 1-800-273-TALK. That's 1-800-273-8255.
米基·米克是我们节目的制作人之一。在那个故事之后的一个节目提示——如果你或你认识的人可能需要帮助，全国自杀预防生命热线提供24/7服务，电话1-800-273-TALK。也就是1-800-273-8255。
By the way, the EMS unions in New York City have been in a dispute with city government. Starting pay for an EMT in New York is roughly $35,000. Paramedics start at $48,000. And when the pandemic started, they asked for hazard pay since they were putting their lives on the line in a way that was more than usual and also for better benefits for their families if they should die on the job. They have gotten nowhere with this. New York City Mayor Bill de Blasio has said he will look into it, but not until the crisis is over.
顺便说一句，纽约市的EMS工会一直与市政府存在争议。纽约EMS入门工资约为35,000美元。护理人员起薪48,000美元。大流行开始时，他们要求危险津贴，因为他们正在以超出寻常的方式冒着生命危险工作，并要求如果他们在工作中死亡能为家人提供更好的福利。他们在这方面毫无进展。纽约市长比尔·德布拉西奥表示会调查，但要等到危机结束。
[MUSIC - SECOND STORY, "WHEN THIS IS DONE"]
[音乐 - 第二个故事，《当这一切结束时》]
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien. People who put our show together today includes Bim Adewunmi, Emanuele Berry, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Nora Gill, Damian Grave, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney, the managing editors Diane Wu and Sara Abdurrahman, our executive editor, David Kestenbaum. Interpreters who helped us with our story in Act One, Samar Jan and Nasir Siddique.
我们今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩制作。今天参与构建我们节目的人包括比姆·阿德温米、伊曼纽尔·贝里、佐伊·蔡斯、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、诺拉·吉尔、达米安·格雷夫、米基·米克、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、本·费伦、纳迪亚·雷曼、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼，执行主编黛安·吴和萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，我们的执行编辑，大卫·克里斯滕鲍姆。帮助我们完成第一幕故事的口译员，萨马尔·简和纳西尔·西迪基。
Esther Perel's podcast, Where Shall We Begin? that we talked about at the top of the show is now available on Spotify and any other platform where you get your podcasts. Special thanks today to Darren Viler, Max Baucus, David Brophy, Sue Benet Romere, Usan Uyghur, and Kayla Gabler. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们在节目开始时谈到的埃丝特·佩瑞尔的播客《我们从哪里开始？》现在可以在Spotify和任何其他获取播客的平台上收听。今天特别感谢达伦·维勒、马克斯·鲍卡斯、大卫·布罗菲、苏·贝内特·罗梅尔、乌桑·维吾尔和凯拉·加布勒。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. While on lockdown these last few weeks, he's been working on his relationship. His wife has an old Al Green record that they like to snuggle to.
像往常一样感谢我们节目联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。在过去几周的封锁中，他一直在经营他的关系。他的妻子有一张他们喜欢依偎着听的老艾尔·格林唱片。
It's an accelerator. It's a relationship accelerator.
这是一种催化剂，一种关系催化剂。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。